hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the video
World Cup 2023 where uh the participants
will be fighting for the chance to be in
the next candidates tournament so the
top three finishers will qualify for the
next video candidates tournament and the
first game that we are showing is the
first game that uh I think is the first
game that actually finished in round one
of this year's video World Cup uh we
have a Turkish International Master
Eddie's Goodell versus Serbian
Grandmaster valley middle
and it's quite uh quite an attacking
game you guys will love it uh one thing
that I do have to mention that it's uh
first 16 moves over the game are known
Theory and then the game just uh
completely collapses so you'll see what
I mean by this and it's a very important
tournament for him uh it is another just
of course the you know five strong
opponents but he also he he already has
two uh Grand Master Norms uh if he gains
one more he becomes a grand master
himself and he qualified for this event
by getting 14th Place in the European
Championship with the top 20 get seeded
directly into the fidi World Cup and uh
maybe you don't know this the top 50 we
are rating do not play in round one so
Magnus Hikaru fabianisha they will not
be playing in the first round they are
seated directly into the second round
and I think William's uh the some
something like 54th seat so he was very
very close to actually skipping the
first round all together now that being
said let's check out this very nice game
it is Goodell uh has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to E4 like I said
it will be a very well known theoretical
struggle Knight F3 Knight to C6 Bishop
to B5 Dory Lopez and now A6 morphe's
defense Bishop to A4 Knight to F6 and
castles and here as this is a classical
game we will discuss some of the options
that black has bishop t7 and B5 are the
top moves in this position but here we
have Knight captures I need for the the
open way to play the morphe's defense uh
D4 and now Bishop to E7 Rook D1 chases
away the Knight but now First Pawn to B5
and there are three options that white
can go for here obviously you can attack
the or you you could capture the Knight
on e4 you could Advance the pawn to D5
and attack the Knight on C6 or you could
just move the bishop back to B3 all
three lines are very very interesting in
the game Bishop to B3 was played but I'm
just gonna quickly show you what happens
if you if you capture an E4 then you get
D5 the root gets attacked Knight
captures an E5 now threatening the C6
Knight Knight captures real captors and
only now B captures on A4 and now after
Queen day one preventing black from
castling Bishop to E6 and now let's say
Pawn to F4 preparing Pawn to F5 so G6
and then y just continues development
Knight to C3 and so on and white will
have a very comfortable game black has a
ruined Pawn structure on the queen side
but that also means that black has the
semi-open B file for his rook and black
does have the bishop fair so it's a
trade-off if you if you uh want to allow
this to Black then you should definitely
play real captors on e4 another thing is
spawn to D5 which will be met with
Knight to C5 just getting your knight
out of Harm's Way and attacking the
bishop on A4 and after the bishop moves
you will play Knight to A5 you will
really go after that bishop and after
Knight captures you will play D6 chase
away the Knight and something like
Knight to C6 captures captures Knight
captures on B3 eight characters you will
castle and okay there's this annoying
Pawn on C6 but as we know from Theory
nothing to be worried about so after
this B5 move we have Bishop to B3
avoiding Rook captures an E4 and D5
altogether and now Pawn to D5 again all
known Theory D captures on E5 Bishop to
E6 and now Pawn to C3 we have Castles by
evich and now Knight B to D2 uh Knights
the C5 attacking the bishop uh and now
okay Bishop to C2 is a well-known move
Knight to F1 is a well-known move here
we have Knight to D4 uh and now Knight
captures on d4c captures and not not
taking the bishop but Knight to D3
attacking The Rook which is fine it is
uh uses this to lift his Rook to E3 then
you can shift it to G3 to attack the
black king Knight captures on C1 Rook
captures and now Pawn to A5 preparing
Pawn to A4 again all known moves uh Rook
e to C3 uh doubling up here going after
the C7 pawn and there is a game where uh
Rook to see it was played I think even a
few games but here we have Pawn to a
four by E which uh and it is now as of
move 16 that we have a completely new
game now look at what happens Bishop
back to C2 of course the bush passed the
move and it's very useful in this
diagonal quanta A3 just messing up um uh
Eddie's uh Queen Side Pawn structure uh
B captures an eight you could also play
B4 I'm just gonna you know point that
out here as it's a very nice move the
problem is if you play Bishop captures
on B4 then no worries you can just play
real characters on C7 and the queen
cannot take the rule because Bishop
captures on H7 and the queen hangs so
you don't really gain all that much by
capturing here and if you play Rook the
C8 again uh you will defend the pawn
with Rook to B1 and you will have a
great position with Black's a Pawn on A3
being weak so B4 will actually be a very
very strong Pawn uh controlling the C5
Square very nicely about okay B captures
on A3 was played we have Bishop captures
and A3 attacking the rook and C1 Rook to
B1 and now Pawn to C5 so all makes sense
those are very very good moves D
captures on C5 and now Pawn to D4 chases
away The Rook Rook the G3 and here uh
for reasons that I will not explain as
it will spoil the moment black has to
play Pawn to D3 and then the game
continues uh it will sort of uh break
the harmony of White's pieces but here
Bishop captures and C5 was played right
away and now availability's position is
completely lost so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this uh
elusive idea for Eddie's while I give
you a couple of seconds it is not an
easy uh combination of the spot you have
to really look deep
foreign
who were able to do it congratulations
on finding this beautiful checkmating
sequence and for those of you who just
won't enjoy the show it is Bishop
characters on H7 with check that's the
move that wins and I'm sure you guys
thought of it because then the queen
comes into the game but what what comes
after that that was the part where you
had to look real deep uh King captures
on H7 and now Queen to H5 with check
King to Jade and of course Queen to H6
now threatening Checkmate uh only one
way to stop this Pawn to G6 and now
comes Knight to the E4 and you cannot
allow Knight to F6 check this ends the
game so Bishop back to E7 and now uh
look at this beautiful move Rook to F3
point is that if Knight to F6 check
lands the bishop capture sorry about
that Bishop captures and pawn captures
once the pawn comes to F6 there will be
no stopping Queen to G7 Checkmate so how
can you stop this you can't push the F
Pawn you just lose the G Pawn uh is
there anything you can do here uh well
you could play Bishop to F5 this sort of
breaks the the harmony again of White's
attackers but it doesn't really do all
that much as Eddies just breaks through
the position with a beautiful Rook
captures on F5 the point is the same you
have to gain control over the F6 square
and if the Rook is captured then Knight
to F6 check you have to capture only
move upon characters and now it's
Checkmate on the next move or you have
to give up your queen but you you don't
have any compensation to give up the
queen like this it's it's a queen and
Rook against the Rooks you are getting
checkmated basically in in a couple of
moves so I have to root characters on F5
Rook the A6 was played uh adding a
Defender to the sixth rank but it
doesn't matter just Rook back to F3 and
he was in this position unmove 28 dead
Valley Middle resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here The Rook
is coming to H3 and it is impossible to
stop Checkmate whatever you do so of
course he just resigned here uh so a
really really great start uh for uh for
young Eddie's who who takes a beautiful
win with the white pieces here he will
have to uh play another game as World
Cup is of course two two classical games
and then uh and then you go into tie
breaks but now he will have to face
evaluated where he will be having the
white pieces and if you've seen him play
he is he truly is a great attacker and
it's not going to be easy so we'll see
what happens uh but yeah first game is
finished and uh what what an uh what a
spectacular finish it was uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
if you have any of your uh games that
you uh any of your favorite games from
the affiliate World Cup 2023 do you use
hashtag suggestion in the comments and I
will go over them I would like to thank
Christoph Mark all the games are best
Lynn Herbert Seth Harper and the
schlurture for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the fide
World Cup until it finishes uh thank you
all I will see soon and have an
excellent rest of your day